[Music]
you are the absolute best actor for the
Incredible Hulk Mark Ruffalo you're
funny and when you're just playing Bruce
Banner you're super chill it's always
amazing to watch a transform into the
big green angry monster sometimes it's
hard to believe it's you but we've seen
the behind the scenes pictures and let's
just say you aren't nearly as
intimidating in a motion capture suit
it's pretty amazing how the special
effects team can turn you into the Hulk
I know it's crazy
shirts now digital effects can make
great movies even better but without
those cool effects the actors look
downright ridiculous
check out these 10 actors who are caught
without digital effects the 2013 space
drama gravity really changed the game
when it came to CGI obviously they
couldn't film a movie in space that
would be impossible but one thing kept
either view the movie relied heavily on
computer-generated imagery in fact huge
parts of the movie are entirely CGI in
many scenes the only part of Sandra
Bullock's character that isn't CGI is
her face people move differently in
space so it was hard to film a lot of
the scenes realistically many of the
scenes were shot in a giant cube of
light with a moving camera the whole
cube was built on a tilt rig it tilted
so they can move all over the place and
even the space suits were enhanced by
the computer we can see that Sandra
Bullock didn't wear helmet and her space
suit was way less bulky she definitely
doesn't look as cool as she did once the
movie was finished it's pretty amazing
what the editors were able to accomplish
with CGI gravity raised the bar and took
computer generation to the next level
stage makeup can go a long way there are
some really great examples of actors who
spent hours in the makeup trailer being
transformed into someone new but
sometimes CGI is necessary to make the
change the dark night movies use both
the Joker's makeup is impressively
creepy but there's another villain in
the movie
Harvey Dent was played by Aaron Eckhart
he was the district attorney for Gotham
City and he wasn't always very ethical
in fact the cops called him Harvey
two-face I heard they have a different
name for me down at MCU that name soon
turns literal when his face is de
figured by fire Danton refuses any skin
grafts and he becomes the villain
two-face it's a really creepy look and
the scene where he reveals his new face
is terrifying but what does that seem
look like without CGI well he looks like
Aaron Eckhart she's got some emotion
captured on his face and it's not scary
at all it's amazing how much the CGI
changed him they definitely could not
have achieved the same level of gore
we'd just make up in 2012 director
Angley brought a best-selling novel to
life on the big screen Life of Pi was a
huge success critics loved it and it
made over six hundred million dollars
worldwide it won four Oscars and one of
those awards was for Best Visual Effects
Life of Pi was about a family from India
who owned a zoo they closed their zoo
and decide to move to Canada to sell the
animals oh shoot
gravy is not meat is taste but there is
a shipwreck and pie is the only human
survivor she has to survive months on
his own and his only companion is a
ferocious tiger they share a small boat
and learn to help and appreciate each
other it's an amazing movie and the
scenes with the tiger are so cool but
when you see the clips of the movie
without the digital effects its
underwhelming in fact it's absolutely
hilarious at times Suraj Sharma plays
spy and he looks at way less cool on an
empty boat in the swimming pool you'll
probably notice there's no Tiger which
is probably a lot safer one of the
sweetest scenes in the movie is when the
tiger lays his head on PI's lap but that
didn't really happen
check out the tiger stunt double it's a
badly
blue stuffed animal with permanent
marker eyes superhero movies always rely
on a lot of digital effects and the
Marvel Cinematic Universe is no
exception a lot of these digital effects
have to do with the monsters and aliens
that invade there are a lot of
explosions but Captain America the First
Avenger had a different problem how did
they make Captain America look less like
Captain America Steve Rogers starts out
as a puny little kid from Brooklyn he's
brave and he wants to fight for America
in World War two but he's too scrawny
and unhealthy Chris Evans had to beef up
to play Steve Rogers and that's
definitely his face and voice at the
beginning of the movie to the little
guys he had to film the shots and let
CGI work its magic the digital effects
team had to make Chris look a lot
shorter and a lot skinnier the change is
drastic it's hilarious to see Chris this
way it had to be hard to act to Stanley
Tucci who played dr. Erskine had to look
down instead of looking Chris in the
eyes
Benedict Cumberbatch is one versatile
actor he can play an arrogant and
cynical doctor turned superhero and
Doctor Strange and he's absolutely
perfect as Sherlock Holmes on the BBC
series Sherlock he also makes a
fantastic evil dragon don't weaken it in
2013 benedict took on the role of Smaug
in The Hobbit film series Smaug is a
vicious dragon who hoards a treasure in
the Lonely Mountain and he is terrifying
the CGI was impressive in the Hobbit
movies but most fans think that Benedict
only lent his voice to Smaug that's not
the case the actor wore a motion capture
suit and acted out the physical
movements of the Dragon it's pretty
funny to see Benedict who is a serious
actor writhing on the floor playing a
dragon the effects team took his
movements and applied them to the
animation of Smaug they also filmed the
motions of his face separately which is
why Smaug is so lifelike in 2009 James
Cameron released a new hit movie that
was totally different from his work on
Titanic avatar was an epic sci-fi film
with amazing visual effects and deep
political messages the movie is about
humans who are colonizing a planet that
is home to a peaceful alien race the
military sends soldiers in as avatars of
the Navi race to study the world one of
these soldiers is attacked and rescued
by Zoe Saldana's character net teary but
Zoe Saldana isn't a blue alien the movie
relied heavily on motion capture
animation to turn the actors into Navi
aliens when you see clips of Avatar
without the CGI it's not nearly as
exciting
Zoe looks way less fierce we loved that
they added fake ears to her mocap suit
thanks to some impressive CGI audiences
were able to lose themselves in the
beautiful world of Pandora as always
held out may be great at motion capture
but there is one actor who is the king
of mocap acting keep watching to find
out who it is oh no
the Harry Potter franchise spared no
expense in bringing the Wizarding World
to life all of the movies use
cutting-edge digital effects things like
Quidditch and the various fantastic
beasts are all done with the help of CGI
but every now and then the directors
went old-school Daniel Radcliffe has
revealed that one of the scariest scenes
was really not terrifying at all in
Deathly Hallows Part 1 Harry and
Hermione go to Godric's Hollow to find
Bathilda Bagshot what they don't know is
that Bathilda isn't really pathetic
she's actually Voldemort snake Nagini in
disguise she lures Harry upstairs in the
form of the old lady then she transforms
and attacks fans jumped and shrieked in
the theatres but there is no scary snake
on set for the attack scene makini was
just a long pole that had a boxing glove
tied to the end someone thrust the pole
at Daniel Radcliffe later the effects
team replaced the pole with a giant
snake it all seems way less terrifying
sometimes you don't need a high-tech
solution let me give you a cut again the
first Pirates of the Caribbean movie was
such a success that Disney created four
sequels and the second movie Dead Man's
Chest is a fan favorite in this film
Davy Jones is a fearsome cursed pirate
life is cruel why should the afterlife
be any different he is owed a blood debt
by Jack Sparrow it's a great
action-packed film with awesome
characters and Davy Jones is truly
terrifying but he's less than human in
his curse form he has tentacles on his
face and Bill Nye it looks from nothing
like that he filmed all of Davy Jones
scenes with a mocap suit green eye
makeup and motion sensors on his face
the effects team then turned all of his
shots into the gruesome pirate captain
bill became completely unrecognizable
it's really amazing what CGI can do we
love all the behind the scenes shots of
Bill acting you can see how expressive
his faces that digital effects really
made the movie what it is fans might
have been skeptical when Mark Ruffalo
took over as the Hulk the first Hulk in
the MCU was played by Edward Norton but
now we can't imagine anyone else besides
Marcus dr. Bruce
mark is a lot like Bruce Banner he's
kind and calm when he's in human form
he's the most soft-spoken of the
Avengers but when he gets angry he turns
into a giant green monster called The
Incredible Hulk
he doesn't have control over his inner
monster for the majority of the film's
I'm always but he starts to realize that
he and the Hulk are one in the same in
the old days on TV the Hulk was a big
guy named Lou Ferrigno who was painted
green but the MCU didn't just want to
use makeup to transform Marc so instead
they used a motion capture suit and the
images of him in this suit are hilarious
it's hard to believe that guy becomes a
Green Giant in the movies we especially
love the fight scene between him and
Thor they put just some green padding
over his suit we can't talk about actors
and digital effects without talking
about the king of motion capture Andy
Serkis has done a lot of mocap work and
he is just the best he really brought
motion capture into the mainstream when
he played Gollum in the Lord of the
Rings movies the transformation was
drastic but it was also controversial he
provided the voice movement and facial
expressions for Gollum but he was passed
over for awards because of the CGI since
then people have realized that mocap
acting is hard work and completely valid
Andy reprised his role as the ring
obsessed halfling in the hobbit
franchise he has also done motion
capture in the plan of the Apes movie
series but his performance as the sneaky
tormented Gollum is incredible seeing
him act out this character is creepy
even though he looks nothing like the
wide-eyed cave dweller Andy Serkis and
the Lord of the Rings effects team
revolutionized motion capture and
brought it to the mainstream
[Music]
that's a wrap now that you've seen these
actions without the digital effects tell
us which one made you laugh the most in
the comments thanks for watching please
subscribe to the things and give us a
big thumbs up so you'll never miss
another video see you next time
[Music]